[Música]
saludos en directo América de Francia 24
más Romero sala ya está con nosotros en
el estudio Mara bienvenida buena mañana
de jueves vamos a comenzar nuestra
sección de salud en Nigeria con un
anuncio importante para las vacunas en
el continente que podría mejorar toda la
situación Ojalá así sea así es en Raúl
muy buenos días es que el gobierno
anunció un acuerdo con un instituto que
se llama el instituto serum de India que
es el mayor productor de vacunas de todo
el mundo para producir vacunas propias
en Nigeria es un acuerdo para la empresa
biobacín que era la mitad propiedad del
gobierno la mitad de una farmacéutica
privada se supone que iniciará la
construcción a finales de este año para
que en 2028 esté en pleno funcionamiento
y pueda producir las vacunas no estamos
hablando de vacunas de Kobe 19 que por
ahora no se plantean sino las vacunas de
inmunización básica de la esquema básica
que se requieren Nigeria por ejemplo
pues la vacuna contra la polio contra el
sarampión contra la Fiebre amarilla
actualmente el país importa todas las
vacunas que el 100% de las vacunas pero
es que además de eso no es una es una
excepción en el continente africano no
en toda la región solo se produce en un
1% de las vacunas a que se usan y se
importan el 99% claro es una muestra una
dependencia muy fuerte del exterior Pero
además no De cualquier manera sino
también de la ayuda humanitaria no
unicef por ejemplo da mil como era 1.500
millones de las vacunas que se aplican
en África entonces también hay una
dependencia muy grande en la ayuda
humanitaria de fondos también por
ejemplo como gavio como hemos visto de
kovacs en el caso de la pandemia que
evidentemente organizaciones lo hacen
con Pues digamos el amor el mayor pues
deseo ayudar del mundo pero no es
suficiente a veces martes de que empezó
la pandemia ha habido esfuerzos para
aumentar la producción africana de
vacunas Sí pues fue uno de los grandes
llamados no Cuando surgió la crisis del
covid 19 también pues cuando se vio que
todos los países africanos llegaban
tarde a la hora de y tener acuerdos con
las farmacéuticas que priorizaban los
países del Norte global De hecho hace
poco más de un año los líderes de la
unión africana prometieron pasar de ese
1% del que estábamos hablando de
producción propia al 60% Entonces
definitivamente este primer repaso de
Nigeria o estas transferencias de
tecnología que hemos hablado algunas
veces también de las farmacéuticas de
algunos Jobs de producción de vacunas en
Sudáfrica son grandes pasos pero se
necesita mucho más sobre todo cuando
revisamos En qué lugares se producen
estas vacunas vemos que solo hay cinco
países cinco lugares de cinco países de
hecho Argelia túnez de Egipto Sudáfrica
y senegal donde se pueden producir
vacunas desde cero incluyendo el
componente activo mientras que hay otros
de estos son solo los principales como
en Nigeria o en Etiopía biobacín es el
que luego quiere pues mejorar su
producción pero en este caso por ahora
solo tienen la capacidad de hacer
vacunas digamos recibiendo el componente
activo desde el exterior poniéndolo en
los viales y luego distribuyéndolo no
haciendo como los últimos pasos de todo
el proceso de la construcción de una
vacuna por supuesto África es un
continente gigante donde vemos que estos
escasos países no son suficientes para
suplir toda la necesidad y también pues
por eso ahí al final entran las ayudas
humanitarias el mismo problema de las
vacunas mar ha ocurrido con la viruela
del mono claro es que Raúl es un
problema estructural que solo se puede
solucionar con mucha inversión con mucha
determinación y de hecho la directora de
la OMS para África hace unas semanas no
es actual esta declaración pero nos
ayuda a contextualizar hablaba
precisamente de este problema también
respecto a la viruela del mono
para África el riesgo es alto análisis
de la OMS revelan Un aumento del 63% de
brotes zoonóticos en la región africana
en los últimos 10 años comparados con la
década anterior no nos podemos permitir
que África se convierta en un centro de
enfermedades infecciosas emergentes
recordemos que el ozonotico es de esas
enfermedades que saltan de los animales
a los humanos que eso sucede mucho en
África la viruela del mono es uno de los
ejemplos no sabemos que desde hace
décadas esta enfermedad está provocando
enfermedades está provocando muertos en
varios países del continente africano
sin que a nadie nunca se le hubiera
ocurrido que la vacuna contra la viruela
que actualmente se está aplicando en los
países del Norte global donde se ha
pasado el brote pudiera usarse también
en los países africanos además
actualmente la vacuna de la variant
nordic cuesta aproximadamente unos 100
euros por dosis algo que es poco
asequible para países de bajos y medios
ingresos y que provoca de nuevo la misma
dinámica no los países ricos entran en
alarma entran en pánico compran la mayor
parte de la producción que es capaz de
hacer la farmacéutica en un año y luego
pues no dejan la capacidad para otros
países que para que puedan usarlo no se
supone que además había un fondo
internacional para posibles rebrotes de
viruela que tenían reservas de esta
vacuna contra la viruela que puede
servir también contra la viruela del
mono pero la verdad es que no se sabe
nada y la información es totalmente
opaca no sabemos si se está aplicando o
no tan fácil es mar como atacar el
problema en el origen no antes de que se
vuelva una pandemia como el covid 19 o
cualquier otra enfermedad No pues ir al
origen a atacar con unas vacunas para
que no se expanda por el mundo pero
bueno terminamos hablando de Kobe 19 los
pronunciamientos de ayer de la OMS si no
habló ayer Pedro sathanom quebrellezos y
la verdad yo creo que es de las veces
que lo he escuchado decir algo más
optimista después de dos años y medio
tan atentos a sus ruedas de prensa
diarias dijo por fin el que estábamos lo
más cerca que nunca hemos estado Antes
al fin de la pandemia Por qué Pues
porque la última semana fue la semana
que menos muertes se registraron de
covid 19 desde marzo de 2020 repasamos
muy rápidamente las cifras 6 millones y
medio de muertes desde ese momento
609 millones de contagios y 12.200
millones de dosis de vacunas aplicadas
en unas campañas de vacunación que han
abatido récords pero que como hemos
visto a lo largo de todo este espacio de
salud todavía dejan mucho que desear
todavía hay muchas desigualdades que
solucionar para que estas pandemias y
estas crisis sanitarias no vuelvan a
suceder en el futuro mar como siempre
Muchísimas gracias por toda la
información de salud Hasta mañana en una
nueva sección de salud aquí en directo
América de Francia 24